[Music]
Tony welcome to the show hi Tim great to
be here I am so thrilled to finally be
having this conversation we have a bunch
of virtual friends and of course the the
good man Scott Belsky is one of them so
thanks to Scott for making the
introduction alright god great guy and I
have I have some suggested topics from
him that we'll get to at some point but
I thought that we could begin with
something that came up before we started
recording I mentioned that I needed to
open up my caffeine I have some yerba
mate' here sitting in front of me and
you said that you don't do caffeine and
one of the questions I plan on asking
you is about alcohol because my
understanding is that you don't do
alcohol either could you describe or
explain why that is in both cases well
the the caffeine thing in the alcohol
are obviously my daily habits or lack
thereof but they happened at different
times and so for me the alcohol was
really an outpouring of when I went to
Saudi Arabia for for two weeks to to be
with a friend there and I stopped
drinking and I it was just before I was
40 40 years old and so I was there for
two weeks and not drinking and all of a
sudden I started feeling completely
better I was sleeping better I was you
know I was waking up better you know
you're like oh I'm not in this fog it
didn't take until 11 o'clock or 12
o'clock to you know to actually be you
know present and so for me it was really
about that feeling much better and then
I was thinking wait a second so if I
drink alcohol well there's the calories
from the alcohol then it's what it makes
me do which is usually eat too much
dessert or any dessert at all definitely
you have less you have less control
there and you're like and then I wake up
in the middle of the night because I get
happy heart because I can't process the
alcohol sugars so it's like and then I
feel like crap the next morning I'm like
why am I doing this to myself when I
feel so much better and I'm like I'm
getting older it's not getting any
better so
let's just cut it out and literally it
was overnight and just cut it out Wow
so that was the alcohol piece right the
trip to Saudi Arabia and what about the
caffeine
well the caffeine you know I basically
overdosed on you know on sugar water or
should aspartame water back in my 20s
when I was at a company called general
magic and so I was probably drinking
between eight and twelve diet cokes a
day right loaded with caffeine and that
was just before the times of those crazy
drinks with all the extra caffeine and
everything but that's what kept me going
but it was it was killing me and so I
just then in there just said I'm
stopping the caffeine and I'm stopping
the sodas whether they were sugared or
not and just just went cold turkey on it
and you know and that helped a whole
process that was the beginning of a
whole process of life changes that I
made from the time I was 24 25 - again
get to this point today so we won't
dwell on this too long but I have a
feeling there's some some good stuff to
unpack here so the cold turkey with
caffeine has some repercussions right
there are some generally some physical
withdrawal symptoms even even a very
very low daily doses of caffeine so two
things that popped to mind number one is
why that particular day alright what was
what made that day different from the
days before and what was the catalyst
and then number two is how did you
handle the the detox period or
acclimation period afterwards well and
we can get into this more later but the
impetus the reason why I did that was I
basically press reset on my whole life
when I was I think about 25 when a
company that I was working at 80 100 120
hours a week at called general magic
totally failed
it became my entire life I didn't I
shouldn't even you know my family to a
certain extent I just wanted to make
this company general magic happened and
so when it was an utter failure and a
disaster I kind of went away on my
journey and then I started rethinking
all kinds of things in my life so that
was that was one big thing but the the
withdrawal the withdrawal was literally
three weeks of insane headaches
it was continual headaches you had to
pop the advil or the Thailand or
whatever it was but it was continual
headaches and even just made me realize
how much that was affecting me and that
I'm glad I got through it but yeah it
was it was it was painful I'm sure it
wasn't not as hard as a typical drug
addition but caffeine is a you know is a
drug but caffeine is a powerful powerful
drug and I never drank coffee either I
probably had two cups three cups of my
life that's it and if we if we rewind
the clock and go way back to childhood
of course in prepping for this have done
a fair amount of reading and I've read
that from the tinkering perspective from
the building perspective which we could
get into your grandfather comes up a lot
I'm curious where you developed or how
you developed your ability to to sell to
market to present to present because
you're not only a good builder you're
also very good at presenting ideas in
very persuasive ways so where does that
come from
well it's a great question so my dad was
a salesman for Levi's Strasse he was a
head sales guide we were he was selling
jeans for 33 or 34 years he was with the
company and so he started there just I
think when I was two years old and so I
watched him all the time going and
selling you know clothes and he gave me
little tips along the way sometimes I'd
actually go with him to his sales you
know a sales meeting where he would be
talking to a retailer and telling him
about the latest line or what have you
or about gold sales goals or what have
you so
I got to watch him do his work and ask
him questions about that and he gave me
some really big tips on that that was
the first one which was it just it's
must be built into my DNA because that's
you know my dad has that skill but then
over time it was really after the
general magic phase then and then you
know starting to understand other
people's languages you know the language
of marketing language of Finance
business and trying to really understand
those languages beyond engineering and
and blending those together and saying
wait a second every single thing is
about communicating in other people's
languages right how would they
understand and then the other one is
then coming from a place in the heart
that's really meaningful when you are
talking the other person's language
about what you're doing and then
ultimately over time through failures
and all these other things is really
understanding talking to them about what
they need and what their problems are
and how you're trying to solve them and
so the more you put themselves in their
shoes so I think it was a continual
thing and then you know being being you
know mentored by Steve Jobs you know
just kind of drilled it all home right
to watch him the absolute master do it
then I picked up more tips and
techniques and refined and refined after
that okay so we'll probably come back to
that as it relates to specific projects
general magic has come up a couple times
and I have heard it described as the
most important company to come out of
Silicon Valley that no one's ever heard
of now it's not quite true that no one's
ever heard of it but it's it's not as
recognizable as a lot of other names of
course how did you end up at General
magic and in explaining that what was
general magic and you can tackle that
however you like sure sure well first
there's a there's a movie out now called
the general magic movie so you can see
it it has the filmmakers told my story
of how to get to how I got there but
beyond beyond that for me it was really
I was I was a passionate geek since the
70s with an apple oh well first with a
you know a computer that was a paper it
had a paper display and it had punch
cards right so I started there and then
an apple - and what have you and so I
was always an Apple fan I was a fan
since I think a 79 or 80 and and then
the Mac came and so then I was a fan of
the Mac and I started to learn more and
more cuz I was really diving in deep it
wasn't just using it was learning about
it learning about the craft and learning
who's behind it and that was all about
you know the Mac team because before
that before Apple before the Mac Apple
was really you know it was just about
the product it wasn't even about Steve
Jobs at that time it was really just
about Apple - when the Mac came it was a
whole set of the the product Steve Jobs
as well as the team behind it and they
you were able to read all kinds of
articles about the team and that's when
I started to really just go who are
these people what are they all about and
so I kept tracking them and watching
where they went some some stayed at
Apple some left some went back to Apple
and back and forth and when I was
getting out of school there was a in the
back of Mac Week magazine there was a
little column that was always about the
rumor mill it was the rumor mill and I
would read that and it said the founding
team from the Mac has gone off to do
this project and this company called
General magic called Pocket crystal and
I was like what is that and so every
week you know you would look for those
little nuggets and that week I found it
and so after that when I when I read
that because there was no internet back
in the day right I read that I was like
okay now was tunnel vision whatever it
does I think I'll figure out what this
company is doing and I need to see if I
could go work there because I was I was
graduating I had a startup at the time
but it was like this it wasn't working I
was I was a it was a tiny pond I was in
in Michigan at the time because it
wasn't the mobile revolution we have
today and so I had to get to Silicon
Valley I had to go see that team and and
then ultimately you know knock down the
door I should say you know kicked in the
door
to get to work there and to add some
color to that so I did watch the
documentary oh and you basically I don't
know how to put this harassed I think is
probably not too far off the the head of
HR and just called and called and and
pestered and pestered until they finally
paid attention is that can you can you
add a little bit of detail sure well
well first it was pestering the people
inside Silicon Valley to find the people
at General magic to talk to so first was
okay I'm was determined to find a person
that at the company I could talk to so I
had to talk to various people I wrote
letters I literally typed letters and
sent them to various VCS and various
people saying who do you know at blah
blah blah who do you know it okay so I
had to find find the person and so then
I ultimately found that person which was
didi young and and started you know
stalking both the company from sitting
at the doorstep trying to get in in the
mornings to meet somebody as well as
placing calls to D to you know to get
that interview to get you know response
from the interview all those things he
took it took probably six let's see I
started in I think April that year and
then I landed the position in November
that year and that was 1991 the my 1991
my recollection of of the film which is
really all I know of general magic is
that you are not the only person who was
say sleeping outside or trying to get a
position at this company what did they
what did they see in you what what were
the elements in your approach or resume
that got you a job do you think well you
know I can't I can speculate but it was
so well first I had already you know at
that time I had a startup company in in
in in in high school with another guy
we're doing educational
to doing selling Apple to peripherals
and writing software for the Apple 2 for
those peripherals that was called
quality computer Joe Gleeson was a great
guy and you know he was just 2 years my
senior and we were it was the two of us
doing that and then after that in school
in college I created a chip firm with
another guy and we we vers engineered
and made a new version of the 65 816
processor in school for the Apple 2 GS
literally a 16-bit version of the Apple
2 because we loved it so much so we made
a processor and actually had it
fabricated and then we also I also had
that a software startup called
constructive instruments with my
professor Elliot solloway at the
University of Michigan and we were doing
educational multimedia software at the
time so I think those few
entrepreneurial endeavors
you know chips and software and and
sales and retail you know mail order not
even eat ale mail order and customer
support I think gave me a little leg up
ABC plus my passion for just please let
me in and they were like oh who's this
kid he's fresh out of school well he's
got all this you know he's got all this
experience
okay let's hire him for a pittance which
it was and we'll give him a try why why
did general magic with this all-star
team I mean just the the superstars of
the time and soon to be or I would say
yes sure soon to be superstars of the
later times fail why did it not what
were they doing and why didn't it work
well general magic was trying to create
what was in essence the iPhone about 15
years too soon okay so you know we know
the iPhone today but back then there
were no digital telephone networks or
mobile networks they were all analog
there was no internet there there was
almost no multimedia and there's the
most people didn't even use email yet
right they and so what we
creating was this iPhone too early but
it was it was a picture of what was to
come so we were too early for the
technology even the processors weren't
fast enough and the battery life was too
short and just so many elements we were
well ahead of our well ahead of the
future let's put it that way and so so
that was one piece but then the other
piece that really really cut general
magic down was I would think it was a
lack of discipline a lack of discipline
about who our customer was what the
product was we were making what the the
timeline was and how we were gonna get
it to market it was literally as an
amazing sandbox to create this next
generation platform with almost no
bounce we created everything from
scratch we didn't leverage almost
anything in the in the that was already
built at the time we decided to make our
own you know chips and everything and
from that point well I shouldn't say
from that point but could you describe
your first contact with Steve Jobs it's
my very very first content yes was at
Andy Hertzfeld birthday Andy Hertzfeld
had his birthday I don't remember which
one it was for nothing
and for people listening or watching
could you could you sure sure just
define define whoo-hoo that figure is
Andy Hertzfeld was one of the principal
software developers of the Macintosh so
he and Bill Atkinson and Susan Kerr and
a bunch of other people created the
Macintosh and they were all at general
magic and so Andy you know he was having
his birthday and so he invited the team
from general magic to come to his
birthday at his house and lo and behold
who shows up I think he was riding his
bicycle at time with Steve who was
literally I think like living five or
six blocks away and so he just you know
rolled up on his on his uh on his bike
and there he was and we were all
gathered around because Steve was
obviously you know busy at next at the
time and
Andy and Andy and Steve had a really
close connection and they would always
talk about you know different
technologies and things and that that
was the time when I first got to meet
him
you know meet Steve was that what were
your impressions at the at the time you
know you're starstruck we're absolutely
starstruck oh that Steve oh my god I you
know and I'm you know I wasn't because
22 at the time something like that so I
just you know you know it's like when
you go up to your you know favorite rock
star something you just don't know
what's a uh you know you're like me
probably just looked at me weird instead
of this crazy kid but that was it it was
but the impression was used he was he
was very definitive in the way he spoke
you know he made sure like this is my
opinion and that's what it is and then
you could argue with him or whatever and
was great it was a great banter that was
fun but I also you have to remember at
general magic I would hear Steve stories
every day every day you'd hear about
something that happened on the Apple 2
or something that happened Apple or on
the Macintosh team and so I had this
vision of Steve and these stories of
Steve from the people who are with him
in the most intense times in the most
celebratory times and what have you so
and I'm sure a lot of those stories were
you know larger than they really were
and you know and what-have-you but so I
had this picture and in times you were
like oh my god absolute genius and other
times you're like absolute madness and
you're like ah should I cower in fear
you know how to mean so like so you
don't really know what to make of it cuz
you have this incredible impression of a
person before you've really met them you
know I can imagine you know the fish was
this big type store isn't all the all
the elaboration that comes in chromatic
storytelling especially when you have
such good raw material to begin with
exactly incidentally so I will ask you
more about Steve but before we get there
I want to talk about your reboot
share post supposes post general magic
so you were full let's go I just suggest
at the end and just you know and then
about a year and a half after
after that yes so what what were the
elements of your reboot and and and and
and then the consequences of the reboot
if you look then say a few years after
that sure yeah I'm sure well look it
started you know and I know you've
interviewed Jim Collins and it was kind
of this I started on the yeah I you know
I'm still on I'm still on the good
journey hopefully one day I'll might get
to the great journey but you know it
first started with you know individual
contribution right so I was like oh I
mean this year to contribute I'm doing
well you know I'm I think I'm performing
at the team and then went the bottom
fell down general magic right just
everything happened and you were working
night and day and all you have is this
tunnel vision and you're like what am i
doing what am I doing with my life and
you know every time you talk to your
parents or I talk to my parents I be
like I got to go I got to work on this
boom you know it's just it was always
just shutting everything down for one
sole purpose and then when that time
happened and it's very dark and lonely
time you say and I had luckily a friend
who actually worked at General magic
she came Sondra Sondra card and she came
and just sat there and talked to me and
just helped me try to get through it and
it was just you know no this is valuable
and this was in all just you and don't
worry about that and you know and just
hey let's and get me out of that element
and let me see beyond because when I was
in Silicon Valley at that moment it was
probably four years and I literally
probably did not go further than a
couple of miles radius away from general
magic and where I lived you know I
didn't go to San Francisco I didn't go
out to the ocean I was just it was it
was a a sole purpose in life was just
that and so she helped to help me you
know kind of take the blinders off and
see more and then as I saw more I
started saying well wait a second what's
the right thing for gentle magic where
would the product go what's the you know
in his so I started thinking about that
and then I also saw we're
is my life go where do I need I can't I
have to start to understand balance and
I started reading and I started you know
designing and thinking about the
customer and thinking about marketing so
you start to see all of these things
that were breaking down at general
imagine you go oh I should have been
involved in that I should have learned
about those things and so so during that
that time was all about redesigning a
product for general magic that I thought
was a success and so I did that I was
learning more about myself through that
and at that moment when I thought I had
something I took it to the general magic
you know powers at B and I said hey this
is what I think is really great and they
said that's nice Tony but we have other
priorities and I was like men of course
it hit me and I'm like oh this thing I'm
working on I can't get these they have
different things they want to do I can't
make this thing real so on the journey
of good to great I decided to go to be a
manager slash leader and so I went and
took that design and I went to different
ones of the licensees of general magic
we had many many big companies who were
working with general magic to create
this device and the service and it was
Sony and Panasonic and another one was
Philips who was working closely with so
I went and pitched my do bus to CEO of
Philips at the time and I said this is
what we can do with this general magic
investment you made and they were like
that's great we let's do this okay now
you're gonna come on and do it for us I
was like whoa what and so literally I
was 24 25 at the time and now you know
through a whole set of things was I was
now the lead of this project and this
new team that I had to build from
scratch in Silicon Valley for Philips to
create this device and so so there was a
failure of general magic and now all of
a sudden be careful what you wish for
you just might get it
and so I I vote I've never managed
people I'd ever do anything so I started
hiring people people I knew and started
building this team and
I was probably the worst manager under
the Sun for the first six months you
know you just like do it this way do it
that way bla bla bla you don't know what
you're doing and so I had to go back and
I'm failing miserably you know I'm in
this big company with these dark offices
it's old it's not a start-up it's
nowhere near like general magic so I
left everything I knew to go to this big
company to do this thing I had no clue
what I was doing and I was failing at it
and so then I had to go on another
journey of like okay what am i Who am I
what what's what what's a great manager
what's a great leader how do I learn
about these things how do I reflect and
see what I'm doing how do I get feedback
and so that was another step right and
then all through that time was also a
physical journey because if you saw the
movie you probably saw me in the movie
yeah I don't look quite like I loved it
like very different and so I'm playing
the long game I wanted to look as
horrible as I could in my 20s so I can
only look better as I got old
so so there was that mental journey and
emotional journey but then there was a
physical journey of healing in every
which way of moving up through that
pyramid of trying to kind of write the
ship and get whole again but then move
well beyond it and take the left take
all those really negative experiences
and turning them into something positive
let's let's explore your process for a
second or maybe more than a second as it
relates to these these these what you
might call sort of phase shifts or
chapter changes when you're asking
yourself what's a great manager how do I
get feedback what does the actual
process look like when you did I mean
are you going to the book store and
buying 10 books and reading 10 books are
you trying to pin people down to grill
them about how they manage what what did
you actually do what was the process
well you hit it on the head nail on the
head there was but books a lot of
reading another one was talking to
people who I trusted
who could give me feedback and then I
started kind of going to a couple of
classes you know and and and and just
doing that well and when sorry to
interrupt what type of classes oh they
were just kind of like management
classes or you know doing little like
questionnaires of your management style
and what's working what's not and then
as I got deeper and deeper I was like
wait a second I need to get deeper into
myself I need to learn much much more
about myself and so how do you do that
you know
athletes go off and get a trainer and
they start working on the training and
they you know like you you know work on
their their their their food you know
what they eat how they sleep how they
work out all that stuff maybe even their
mental abilities and so I was like well
if I'm gonna do this I got to know
myself really well and I'm and given a
lot of the stuff that happened growing
up because I went to 12 schools in 15
years I was you know you know a
transient kid in a way and so I didn't
so there was all these social
interactions that I had or I did not
have because I wasn't with a group for
very long right
sometimes sports gives that to kids
because they they learn how to work on
teams but I never had that because I was
always moving and so I decided that
what's the best thing to do is I'm gonna
act you because I was reading all these
books about psychology you know the road
less traveled I was reading you know I
was also a philosophy minor in in in
college so I was also going back to some
of that going back to some psychology
and things I said okay I'm just gonna go
find a person that I can go talk to
about everything so I went to a
psychologist I just I was I wasn't crazy
I just decided I'm gonna go talk to
somebody who should know something about
this so I literally went to one and a
half to two hour sessions twice a week
for almost a year and a half and
literally just diving deep into
everything and said I had this in
yeah I had this experience today I had
that experience today and it gave me the
time for me to process it myself right
and just you know the person would ask
me questions the the doctor would ask me
different questions but then and then I
was like oh oh I didn't think about it
that way I didn't see it from that angle
oh okay and so I got to go really deep
into so many pieces of my life that that
was just wow it was just like huge
lights were you know flashing and you're
like oh my god
and all of a sudden you know the changes
started occurring it wasn't just doing
but it was learning the fundamentals and
learning not just by reading a book but
actually seeing it in your day-to-day so
I could bring examples from everyday
into the sessions I just talked about
them zebb that makes them it does make
sense how did you find the psychologist
how did you pick this person oh geez Wow
how did I do that
or how hot it could be I think it was
just a recommendation from from some
friend from a friend yeah it was a
recommendation what were some of the
results that you saw outside of the
sessions some of the some of the
outcomes for you I think it was you know
empathy there was a lot of empathy
putting yourself in other people's shoes
and understanding what they were
thinking how they're acting how they
might be reacting to certain words that
you're saying different approaches to
leading and motivating certain things
about the decisions I made every day and
how I could go about making different
decisions how about just reenable
interactions again like I said I was the
geeky kid in the corner I was the new
kid all the time right and you know if
you're the new kid all the time you're
gonna have certain tendencies and you're
gonna fit in really fast but you're also
not going to make deep connections so
it's those kinds of things that you had
to grapple with
and really tease apart and learn about
yourself and so that was like an N and
so that was where you know the physical
change the mental change the leadership
changed to allow me to really propel
beyond and not just you know learn
through lots of mistakes there I learned
through mistakes but you were it was a
quick iteration because you could learn
the it wasn't you were you're not
learning about the symptom but you're
learning about the root cause right if
it's are trying to fix the root cause or
at least manage it why did you go
through 12 schools in 15 years well
because of my dad's job cuz right your
dad's job yeah my deck so he was
wherever the business at Levis because
it was taking off he remembered in the
70s Levi's oh you're too young you don't
know this Levi's was was literally like
was a precious precious commodity like
they were trading Levi's jeans as
currency in Russia on the black market
it was that sought-after thing maybe
like supreme is or was you know it was
that kind of thing and so my dad would
always go to various places where they
were either starting and rolling out
Levi's because it wasn't everywhere it
was just in certain places so starting
up new territories or propping them up
or or fixing them in some way so we
would move from place to place because
my dad was ambitious and he was really
good at sales and and so they kept
promoting him and moving him up the
ranks and giving him harder and harder
work you know that's what happens right
when you're successful they only give
you more all right as a friend of mine
put it he said your reward for winning
the pie it in contest is more pie what I
know that we're going a little memento
nonlinear with the way that I'm asking
questions but I wanted to ask this
earlier what what made your dad so good
at sales what are some of the things
that made your dads so good well he's
he's a very personable guy so he gets
along and you can see it in his face
he is not a guy can lie alright and he
and neither am i I got
from as well and he said to me one day
after the meeting guy there was some in
a meeting he was in a sales meeting I
was there and I saw him and he laid out
the whole line of clothes and showed
this I think it was I don't remit was
Bloomingdale's or Macy's at the time
something and he said okay these are the
hot sellers in our line these aren't so
good
I wouldn't recommend you buying these
blah blah and I was like dad what are
you doing you're supposed to set
everything and he goes no I'm not
supposed to sell everything I'm supposed
to sell the things to the what the
customer really should have and they're
gonna be successful with and if I don't
have what they're gonna be successful
with I'm gonna recommend my competitor
and tell him that they should go there
instead of this piece of apparel or
whatever because I'm gonna earn the
trust and respect and I'm it's not about
a transaction it's about a relationship
and they will come back to me every day
every week and know that I'm the person
they want to talk to and I'll be first
and if I have the best stuff I'm gonna
get the biggest orders but if I always
sold all the stuff that was dog you know
just to make my quarter to quarter
whatever not it was to crack I am gonna
lose that relationship and everything in
life is about your relationships and how
you treat them and how you you know
whether the times are down or whether
times are good or times are bad and so
that was a key piece that I took away
from that day and net will never forget
that is a great story what a great story
what a great lesson to man what a gift
when you later in your career were
giving advice on managing because you
talked about developing empathy you
talked about this personal
transformation later on when people
would come to you as novice managers who
are kind of trying to build the plane
while they're mid-flight what what type
of advice do you give to new managers
who are maybe good product people who
have somehow been promoted into a
management role but never prepared for
it what what type of advice or training
or recommendation
do you give those folks well the what
always inevitably happens with all new
managers is they have a difference with
another manager somewhere where their
customer their supplier or whatever it
is they have a difference with a manager
that's inside the team and usually
they'll come and complain to me about
that person or whoever they're having a
problem with that team and then use the
other team member will come up and I
always would say to them I'm like look I
can sit here - I'll give you some advice
but at the end of the day I am NOT gonna
rule on this I'm not gonna sit here and
take aside I said because whatever side
I take you won't be happy or the other
person won't be happy it will never go
well I said the best thing you can do is
whenever you have these issues is you to
get in a room and speak like adults
instead of complaining you know whiny
children and you get in a room and you
hash it out and you try to speak like
adults to each other and try to work it
out and if you still can't work it out
come get me but don't what most people
do is they rant over here and they rant
over here but they never try to make a
bond with that other person to try to
find common ground and work from that
kind of like the polarization of our
politics today right and you got to get
in the room you got to get and that's
the biggest step for conflict resolution
and to build your relationships since
inside the organization so that you can
go further because you're gonna always
all need to work together this is it's
not a zero-sum game maybe some companies
are but in the ones that I had was never
a zero-sum game we needed each other and
we need to work each other and you can't
always get your manager involved to do
that and so I was always about sure I'm
always about learning by doing and then
doing the education on the back end in
other words have the failure moments
work through work through it and try to
figure it out yourself and then go read
about it and go oh now I get it so it
kind of locks it in so a lot of people
learn than do I like to do fail then
learn are there any particular books
that you have found useful or recommend
two people related to management or
communication anything like that
management and communication yeah yeah
or communication I'm just wondering if
somebody came to you hypothetically in
there and they said Tony I want to hash
it out with this guy but you know I'm a
miniature version of you I'm running RIT
redhot I'm in sixth gear and I think I'm
just gonna not have the tools to say
have this conversation without getting
really excited or or managing it in a
way that they won't be as productive as
it should be so how should I prepare for
it right sure
what where might you point them or what
might you say to them well I think that
there's one book which is it really does
up there's two there's two books
actually one book which is getting to
yes if you've ever read that book
getting to yes yep right give me another
guys yep right getting to yes is one and
that's all about telling a story right
and I'm being there and telling a really
great story for why people should say
yes to whatever you're proposing so
building that the other one is who moved
my cheese yeah right that's another
really simple book you don't have to go
through all of this psychological kind
of you know you know heavy books to get
to very simple lessons right and so who
moved my cheese is when you know
basically something's changed and you
don't like it anymore and it's out of
your control and then you know getting
to guess was all about trying to find
the common ground and getting someone to
see your side and hopefully getting them
to say yes so those two things are very
simple books but they're a good starter
place to get people to work together
thank you so I'm looking I'm looking at
normally I would apologize for this I'm
looking at this is gonna get meta for a
second I'm looking at my iPhone which
normally I would apologize for but it
seems very appropriate here and I'm
gonna look at my notes because there's a
text from our our mutual friend Scott
Belsky with a few suggestions and this
is going to be the return to Steve in a
way
so he mentioned I'll just read a few
things so he's one of the rare people I
know who can work across atoms and bits
as he describes it and then he said he
has a ton of ton of Steve stories from
early days of iPhone and iPod how
decisions were made counterintuitive
bets taken at the time so could you tell
a story about any decision or
counterintuitive bet from the Steve days
counterintuitive bet well you know Apple
was fighting for its life at on the ipod
base right so that was pre iPod so a
counterintuitive bet was specifically
Steve saying we are going to build you
know iPod that was called dulcimer
literally the company at that time frame
was 200 and I think it had 500 million
dollars in debt and 250 million dollars
in the bank and it was breakeven
quarter-to-quarter
right and Steve was like we need to do
this thing it was a code name called
dulcimer which ultimately came iPod but
we need to do this project and he he
said okay I was I was a consultant
whipping this thing up and then he was
like okay you're gonna come on board and
you're gonna make this happen and the
people in that room he said look this is
going to happen and if anyone gets in
your way
have them call either someone in this
room or call me and we're gonna take
care of it and so literally there were
people who put roadblocks in you know we
say it's the corporate antibodies that
set in and say wait a second we're
struggling for our life right we're
struggling for our life for the Mac we
got to put all of our resources in the
Mac we can't be you know going in a
different direction we have to like all
be you know and you're just you're a
consultant who are you kid you know and
I'm like I need these you know I need
some people to help and they're like no
no no no and then literally I'd call in
the air cover hey I need some help
whoever that was and then you know that
person and that person whoever was in
the way you know after about four or
five calls it got around the company
like if I asked you I need help you just
say yes
don't because you don't want to know
what's gonna come your what you know
what bombs gonna come and hit you
otherwise and so that was a very
counterintuitive thing and it was
totally you know guarded by Steve and
that and the the management or a part of
the management team at the time what
what gave him the confidence to make
that type of decision or maybe
confidence is the wrong label to apply
to it I'm not sure but but if whether
you have to speculate or if or if you
know what's what gives or gave him the
ability to make that type of of
commitment and decision well you know I
saw a lot of decisions and a lot of
stuff after the first iPod you know kind
of green light to start to keep going
right so I so I'm gonna speculate based
on those you know ten years of decisions
I saw what I think happened at the iPod
thing which was literally almost every
time we had to make a big bet a very big
decision that would be you know kind of
high high risk put the company at high
risk it was always because we were under
threat yeah okay so the iPod was because
they tried everything to get the Mac to
go over three years and it wasn't going
and it was we have to try something
different we tried everything on the Mac
no one wants to move off Windows PCs
what are we going to do differently and
so this looked like the first thing that
could happen mp3s were taking off all
the mp3 players at the time were just
horrible and iTunes at the time after
Apple bought iTunes from with Jeff Robin
basically started gaining traction and
Max were just starting to sell as
multimedia machines you know you could
do your music on them and he's like okay
now if we get an iPod maybe it will
cause more people to want to because
it's differentiate it's not just burning
CDs or something people will buy more
max
because this iPod will allow them to do
something that nobody else can do not
especially definitely not on the PC side
so we were under threat right right
Michael Dell said to the world like Oh
Apple should you know pack up and go
home give all the money left over to the
shareholders and stop right so that's
the situation it was and he didn't want
that to happen so he was looking for
anything that could possibly break out
and he's a lover of music we were all
lovers of music or are lovers of music
and so I think he made that bet and it
wasn't too expensive to go off and do
yeah I what what is the timing for just
as one piece of it iTunes within Apple
when it's first being sort of prototyped
and and developed inside of Apple what
would have the timing been on that in
terms of year but they'd like 2000-2001
yeah so iTunes I believe was bought in
late 2000 it might have been no no do
you know middle of to early to middle of
2000 it was bought and and then it was
it was quickly rejiggered to be at Apple
product to be iTunes and then they
started seeing it taking off and they
wanted it to work with mp3 players and
that's when it all
that's when Apple said oh we need a
device and that's when I got the call
and you know everything came together so
it was early 2000 and then we had the
discussion about the iPod I was brought
in in late January 2001 and then I would
see signed off on it in the third or
fourth week of March of 2001 and then we
shipped it in the first week of October
that year in 2001 so it was that fast
built the whole team built the whole
thing it was you know was crazy crazy
crazy schedule so just as a small world
story of sorts so mm I had just moved to
Silicon Valley and I was working in San
Jose living in Mountain View and
I had this tiny tiny tiny bedroom which
cost like five million dollars a month
and a ranch I was driving my mom's
hand-me-down piece-of-shit minivan this
thing was a disaster and in my apartment
complex there's this guy yeah sort of
across the way there's this little
concrete pond I mean it was it was
really pretty pretty hilarious but
perfectly comfortable place and this guy
I'd want to get anybody trouble so I
won't mention where he's from but he
would always be smoking late at night
and I was a night owl so I'd be up at
like 2:00 3:00 in the morning working on
this first company and guy has gone and
we talked for a few minutes and was sort
of our nightly chat and I saw this guy
get he worked at Apple and he got
progressively more and more Haggard
looking and and it turned out at the
time he didn't give me any name or
anything but he's like look my I can't
even make sense of this anymore can you
come over here and give me your thoughts
on this interface because I've just been
looking at it for like 20 hours straight
and it wasn't I later realized a very
early sort of mock-up of iTunes yeah it
is a while to look back but this guy he
was working so hard he was a good
employee I mean he probably I'm sure
wasn't supposed to show me but he needed
a second opinion and it it's just
reflecting back on what that has become
does it still hit you your TED talk is
wonderful talks a lot about habituation
but when you see people walking around
with one of these devices right an
iPhone or some of these products nest
that you've been so critically involved
with does it ever still just kind of
stop you or is it so you are are these
these things so ubiquitous that it's
become invisible to you well you know
when it becomes everywhere and becomes
mundane basically you know just like
whatever and then you kind of look back
oh yeah I forgot I was involved in it
because you're just using it everyday it
wasn't like so so to me you know
in our business whatever you did was
ancient history it's always about what
you're doing or what you're planning to
do right so we could never you know as
we said on the team we'd only celebrate
for a nanosecond and move on and if you
look at iPod we were fighting for our
life with every generation iPod wasn't
success to this third generation right
so the first one was like cool and then
it was nobody bought it second one cool
for a little while then a few more
people bought it the third one is where
that started happening and then when
iPhone happened you know we had a lots
of success underneath our wings at that
point but then it was like we're taking
on these monster companies just like we
took on Sony is like yeah and this is
really hard can we do this and like and
we did it and then but we're like but
that's not enough we got to do the next
one in the next one and so it's a
breathless journey that you have and
then finally when you're there you're
like oh yeah we did all that and then
you go and try to like write down the
history and like wow we sure did a [ __ ]
ton of stuff you know but you know it's
or after having that general magic
experience and ten years of failure for
me in the valley it was always a hope we
would be successful but never a it's
gonna be because I already went through
that and I went through that physical
and emotional pain so I never got to
that point where yes oh my god we the
champions like that left my body it was
always about climbing the next part of
that hill or that mountain - then
ultimately get - you know making
something that's really great and you
know those things today are still
evolving and it's great to see we're
gonna talk about a lot of your post
Apple experiences but before we get
there you mentioned early in the
conversation that you learned a lot from
from Steve what what are some of the
things that you learned from Steve or
picked up from Steve any anything yeah
anything at all the the biggest one was
storytelling storytelling storytelling
always whatever you're doing have great
stories and great analogies because you
need to
relate to people on their level and if
you can give them great analogies so if
you're trying to whether it's a product
story or software story but even if you
try to change the way you know you're
doing a process at work or who who are
the right vendors we should be working
with you need a great story behind that
so you can get people on board and
understand the facts through a fun way
of learning about the facts if you know
what I mean we went through this and
here's the step one of our journey step
two of our journey this is what we
learned and now we're at this decision
today here are the things that we want
to make sure we avoid and from the past
but we need these things in the future
it's going to be risky but telling those
stories and then and if you can find the
analogies by which everyone can relate
and it makes it really just drop dead
simple do you have any examples of
analogies whether from Steve or from
your own journey later that that you
could use to illustrate sure you know
like Steve had this perfect one he did
with Walt Mossberg on stage which was
like you know the Mac was like bringing
you know a glass of ice water to
somebody in hell yeah right you're like
oh yeah of course you're like oh it's so
refreshing I need this I've been dying
for so long you've you've now saved my
life in a way and so that was one just a
classic example of of that but you know
we try to do that all the time in our
marketing you know when we were at nest
in our marketing we try to do that in an
iPod iPhone but I you know this
sometimes you don't even need an analogy
though if you can really get it crisp
and that was the first tagline for the
iPod which was a thousand songs in your
pocket right it is probably the shortest
most concise most dramatic tagline of
any product ever in existence right and
when you hear that you'd like we always
use that we hold that up is kind of the
measuring stick for everything we do
after that like how do we get to that
point with our marketing or how do we
get to that point
whatever we're trying to say to get it
so crisp so understandable for everyone
that is like oh my god duh
yeah that it's such it's such a
beautiful elegant example of the
benefits versus features right and
instead of what you saw a lot at the
time which was the specs right the
megabytes or the feeds and speeds the CD
speeds exactly and man it's also the
type of tag line that hits that sweet
spot of perfectly understandable and
shareable right which is it's it really
did just just read that needle perfectly
after a below what do they think of
analogies yeah one other thing and
analogies is if you can have a great
analogy for someone they will continue
to repeat that to everyone else so even
if they didn't get all the details and
everything else and they they can't
articulate exactly the story or all the
you know the house wise and what's they
can tell the analogy and everyone goes
oh now I get it right yeah so for the
most part and so that's another thing is
trying to give give the people your
listeners or the people you're trying to
persuade a superpower give them that key
line to make them feel like they really
know what's going on and then they can
reiterate and then like yes I'm in the
know and it's cool totally and that that
single analogy or that single line that
one memorable phrase at least in my
experience also often acts as an anchor
for other pieces of information right
but the they need that first anchor in
order to access that chain of recall
that gives them the other details
exactly they go oh now I'm listening I
get it now I'm listening yeah we were
yeah you're right you're right no in all
the videos that I've watched a view and
certainly just having this conversation
you you seem like a guy who's very
comfortable at high rpms and I read and
certainly you can't believe everything
you read on the Internet so feel free to
start check but I read that upon leaving
Apple your goal was to get bored
and they put it in quotation marks this
is from The Guardian and then he
traveled around the world with his young
family for a year and a half put his
children in French preschool etc I was
the goal to get bored and if so could
you explain what that means
so getting bored and and a lot of people
who come to me for career advice so
people who worked for me worked with me
whatever they they come and say Tony I'm
thinking about doing the next thing and
you know you get a point in your career
where you have the ability to take time
to make decisions
most people very early on their career
you know you have to you have to eat you
know you have to jump from jail you have
to jump from lily pad to lily pad and
you have to make sure it's gonna be
solid stable and everything else because
you're worried about it worried about
your life your your perhaps your family
you get a certain point your career
where you can actually take a pause you
can breathe and you can think again and
you can get inspired and you can and so
when I say get bored which is get out of
the process you're in the day-to-day
grind and it edited it and just saying
okay I've taken as much information as I
can in this week or these two weeks of
figuring out where I'm jumping to and
I'm just gonna jump to it I'll you know
damn the torpedoes it's just gonna I'll
make it work kind of a thing and so what
I say to people is no don't you know
they're like oh I have this great
position now in title if I stop I'm
gonna have if I stop now and I don't
take a job over there I'm gonna lose it
all and we'll have to start from zero
again and I'm like no you don't what you
need to do is if you do your career
right between every eight to ten years
you're going to have a different chapter
of your life of your career if you if
you want to do anything substantial it's
probably between eight and ten years
some people think it's four to five I
don't think that if you're doing
something that's really important and
different and so when you win those
pauses come up or when those big
transitions happen you need to think
very clearly because you are about to
get married for ten years or eight years
to something else that you're going to
your heart and soul into it's gonna if
you're if you're choosing correctly
right it's not about the money it's
about the mission and what you want to
learn and what you want to challenge
yourself with and deliver to the world
and whatever that is and so you should
take the time out get bored get out of
the rat race get out of that and I got
you know a sliver of time to think about
the future I think about you know I've
made my future is today two weeks two
months maybe after that it's a blur it's
you maybe holidays but other than that
it's like okay I don't even know what's
out there get the time to get bored
spend three six months if you can or at
least two or three weeks outside of that
get bored just put away all of your
things maybe go clean up the garage or
whatever it is right and through that
you're gonna start to think differently
you're gonna act all slightly
differently and your mind might open up
to other sources of inspiration other
problems other things where you start to
go oh now I see differently I'm not just
gonna go and make go to run to the
competitor because I understand the
space and run to the competitor and go
work for them because they're gonna give
me a better job but I want to go to a
whole different thing that I want to
learn about that's gonna challenge me so
I'm not just checking in every day and
doing my work but I'm actually growing
through that this is great I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep keep going with this keep
going this Themis could you give me and
it's a personal example from your life
of of doing this whether it's current
day past anything that that comes to
mind that you think is makes for makes
for a good illustration well you brought
it up already
which was you know the time that we went
around the world for a year and a half
and traveled okay
the whole goal there was to get out of
the same place at that point my I had
been four let's see 18 years 19 years
with Silicon Valley you know was to get
out see the world with our kids who were
one and two at the time
they were we didn't see him very much
because my wife also worked for Steve
right my wife our for Steve I work for
Steve so we were busy busy busy helping
Apple and so when we had kids we came
home one day and we weren't with them
you know we learned that we weren't with
them they were like running to the nanny
when they had a problem instead of us
because they didn't know who we were so
we're like this is not working so we
said we're gonna change everything and
go out and understand other things in
life and try to be as with a family and
through that we went to many different
countries and lived in different houses
lived in you know in Spain and France in
Hawaii and different parts of California
anyways moved all around and through
that journey and going to different art
museums and talking to people living in
different houses that's where the idea
for nest came up was literally we're
living in all these homes around the
world with all the same problems so
you're living in Spain and you're living
in Fresno you live in Hawaii then you're
living and you're like wait a second
they all have the same fundamental
problems with their home controls and
things and at the very same time I was
designing a house in remotely in Lake
Tahoe
so between Lake Tahoe designing you know
I was that was a great way that like
distraction right it was it was
something I always wanted to do so I was
working on that and then living in these
different places and experiencing the
same problems in that design here and
understanding that I saw different ways
of living all around I was like wait a
second I think we can fix this problem
and step by step that nest was created
over you know kind of a nine-month
gestation thinking reading learning
experiencing to then come up with that
solution that if I was still in Silicon
Valley I would have never came up with
where are you now
right now I'm in Paris in Paris and
where do you spend most of your time
these days is it in and I suppose along
with that why Paris so Paris happened
during
trip that that that year-and-a-half
travel Paris was only supposed to be a
two-week kind of quick adult we're gonna
come here and be in Paris it's gonna be
a great parents experience but the kids
not so much and we got here and then we
started looking around and really living
you know in those two weeks just go into
this various odd dance and things of
that nature were like wait a second this
is great kids especially in their age
and it's like oh this is wonderful my
wife's like this is great
let's just stay and we just because we
had that ability we just stayed we just
continued to stay in Paris and and and
then through that we met all kinds of
very interesting people learned about
the culture learned about the language
and just fell more and more in love and
I was going to you know various museums
and learning about those artists and
learning about their periods in time so
like Oh
certain pretty you know Picasso Etta's
blue period in his next period in its
next prey and each time they take these
breaks there's like all we sing we're on
those breaks getting inspiration just
like they did it like this is cool and
so Paris just became part of us and then
the other piece of the puzzle was we're
like well wait a second we can go back
to Silicon Valley but what our kids
really gonna learn we're like they could
learn a language it was always my dream
to learn a second language growing up in
the Midwest growing up in the US you
know you don't really think a second
language at least in the 70s and 80s was
important today obviously it's more and
more important especially in California
and other states Texas and those things
but I always wanted to do that I was
like well we could give that to our kids
they could learn that they're gonna
learn socialization of course but they
can't learn math and history and science
but they could learn a language let's do
that and let's give that gift to our
kids that I always wish I had and so
that was the the Paris connection and
then we kept coming back every summer
our kids always stayed in French
programs and became fluent in French and
and then ultimately we bought here and
then after I got done with Google Nest
my wife just said hey we have a place in
Paris let's just move I'm like let's do
it done that's that's how it all that's
all it'll happen but since then
since that happened in 2016
yet 2016 we've also decided to branch
out further and now we spend a lot of
time in Southeast Asia and in Paris and
we go back and forth and put our kids in
school there have you know home
schoolers that help our kids when we're
in different places and those things
just because as you've said so many
times experiences are incredibly
powerful things to learn from so it's
it's knocking the parents off the
foundation just like the kids are
learning for the first time and we learn
as a family unit and we figure out
things like when you're in Indonesia
what what what's the currency why do
they act this way why is it this way oh
my god that's really cool why don't we
do that in the developed world why do we
do all of these different things just it
just helped to build you know I think
our family and and the way our kids see
the world it's it's such an incredible
gift that you're giving of course
yourselves but your kids as well as an
entirely different lens through which to
view not just the physical world but
these are constructs and concepts and
labels and language that make up our
realities it's it's it's really exciting
makes me excited some in here in some of
your episodes you talk a lot about
language and I think you also had that
in one of your your the papers you wrote
in school or something about language
and you know when I was listening to
some of your pockets I'm like yes you
are absolutely right there's these
containers that's called language and
when you see how differently they speak
in a different language and what words
are meaningful and what words they don't
even have in that language you're like
oh that shapes the culture in a dramatic
way and that's the kind of things where
you go you know it's like brain food at
least for me where you're like oh my god
I've never saw thought of that problem
that way before
ah it brings such clarity or bring such
you know resolution to how you see the
world in many ways in different respects
so it's cool so this might seem like a
90-degree turn I don't I don't think it
is but I want to bring it up and was
planning on bringing it up anyway
plaster
yeah plastics plastics why are why are
you so interested in plastics plastics
well when you live in Southeast Asia you
start to really understand plastics
because they're all around you in on the
ground in the water even in the air and
you see it everywhere and you start
saying why do they have this problem and
in other parts of the world we don't
seem to have that problem
and so as over the journey of the past
year and a half I've come to realize a
lot of interesting pieces about plastics
and so for me plastics are a problem
that we all have it just is hidden in
many parts of the world from us because
there is waste management management and
quotes it's taken away and we don't see
it any longer but it is still an
incredible problem and it's in some ways
a blessing that there is not waste
management in many of these places so
you can see the damage we're doing to
the environment firsthand and it's not
just about gathering it up and it's not
just about recycling which everyone
tells you about it's really a problem
with our usage and the material itself
and how we use it how we design with it
that we are burying our future
generations in this toxic mess we talk
about co2 all the time we talk about
coal plants we talk about climate change
we have all kinds of things behind
climate change that are going to be
problems for future generations that we
also have to pay attention to and in
some cases some of these other things
just like plastics is actually
contributing to our climate change issue
as much as its environmental damage if
for 500 years and so being in Indonesia
you know you really you really feel it
viscerally and you're just like where
there's a big problem this is what I
love this is when I get like my brain
turns I'm like this is a big problem how
can we solve it and this is not a
problem with like a societal problem
this
is truly a design problem this is we
designed this mess we got to design
ourselves out of it
just like we have to do in climate
change so I'm like that was us it it hit
me so hard that I'm like okay how are we
gonna design our way out of it and so I
spent the last year and a half learning
about it okay so so I can yeah that's
not me yeah yeah no it's a great dot dot
dot I want to I want to I want to pursue
that dot sure I I want to talk about
possible solutions or directions for
solutions but before we get there
because I'm so interested in how your
mind approaches something like this how
do you begin to dissect a problem that
that could have such a broad umbrella
right there's so many possible
directions to go how do you even begin
as someone who knows how to build from a
design perspective or other perspectives
how do you begin to deconstruct that hmm
well let's just let I'm gonna just go
back through the plastics thing you know
yeah I'm not a plastics expert by any
means or at least I wasn't I'm trying to
get there even though the products that
I helped to create had plastics in them
I really didn't know a lot about the end
of life of plastics on that stuff so I
was like okay there's all this waste
everywhere in Indonesia well why don't
we just do what we do in the US we'll
just recycle it right and we'll just
make sure there's good collection and
then you kind of dig in and you start
learning about that you go so you try to
just model saying oh we're just gonna
fix it by doing what we do there and
then you start asking more questions
like so where does that go exactly and
so you just kind of dig deeper and you
just dig deeper and you just keep saying
you know I always say you know you can
usually get to a great answer or a
really great question by asking why
about five times why this why that why
this and so literally the the process
for me about plastics was why why why
why and and you just kept and you never
just took anybody at face value for the
answer you just kept digging and so for
me it's been all research and then I got
to the point where it's like wait a
second this all logic does not apply
here wait a second
whose someone's giving this a you know
selling us a story about how how
plastics are really you how plastics are
really treated at the end of life that's
not what happens what really happens and
you keep diving deeper and deeper so for
me it's really about that you start to
apply things and just never give up till
you find the real root cause and then
unwind right don't just try to patch so
that's that's how that's how I got to
you know and I'm still asking a lot of
wise but I got to really I think a good
point at least on some pieces of the
plastic issue that we have can you talk
about where you are now in your sheet
absolutely so it first started with
collection waste management and let's
just collect it all and make sure it
just doesn't get there and then we'll
recycle it then
and so what I'm mostly talking about now
is there's two types of plastics
there's plastics that are durable things
things like you know your car bumpers
and they last for five or ten years and
you know and they're they serve a
purpose and they're and the material is
really good for that okay then there's
another purpose which is we call
ephemeral or single-use or very low use
plastics where we're using this product
once or a couple of times and then we
discard it okay so there's still a lot
of things that need to be done on the
durable side and it's not perfect by any
means but if you look at what's growing
exponentially is packaging and
single-use and these ephemeral
applications that are going wild and in
fact many of the petrochemical companies
like the petroleum companies right
they're actually not worried about
electric vehicles taking away all the
gas because they see these
petrochemicals all these plastics and
these things being consuming oil over
time and so you're like wait a second
the petrochemical gals aren't scared
because we're using so much plastic this
in packaging and it's growing crazy so
let's talk about that so is it really
recycling so I'm talking about packaging
and recycling you know like okay so I
dig deeper and I you know I started
recycling University of Michigan back in
the 80s
and so when you start to learn about it
you find out that just because it has
the recyclable label on it it's not
recycled
it's literally buried or burned setting
off toxic ashes literally it's buried or
burned or it ends up in the environment
like we see you know as litter or in the
oceans and you're like wait a second
just cause it has a recycling label
doesn't means it recycled and very very
few of them are actually recycled and
you're like okay this is a problem and
it's growing exponentially and even the
best countries in the world with all
these resources cannot afford to recycle
like because it doesn't make any
economic sense so I can't wait a second
so what happens to all this stuff once
it's burned or buried then you find out
it turns into micro and nano plastics
that remain in the environment for 500
years and then you learn it's in think
everything we drink it's in the air we
breathe it's in the soil that it's in
the soil it's in the water it's in snow
it's it's it's falling down as rain or
snow in the on the polar caps you're
like wait a second this plastic is
everywhere it's going to it's going to
be everywhere for 500 years and it's
these tiny nano plastic just because it
goes away it's still there and you're
like well what does that do it goes into
our body and typically those nano
plastics pick up bio accumulative toxins
and those toxins literally latch onto it
and then they go into our bodies and
then they go into our blood streams and
so we have very very early research it
isn't published but I've talked to a lot
of researchers that when those nano
plastics get into us it's like asbestos
and it causes inflammation in the body
and the body attacks it and it could
cause all kinds of things we still have
to do the correlation so people like oh
yeah it's nano plastics don't worry
about it's in your water but it's small
parts per million but look I think it's
just a lot of people telling us these
things don't matter just like they said
cigarettes don't matter or other it's
sugar doesn't matter it matters and it's
in us in it's in our environment and
we're polluting for generations so okay
so now we have this nano plastics
problem
it's gonna be there for 500 years
packaging's going crazy it can't be
recycled so what do we do so we have to
come up with new materials and new
designs for all this packaging to allow
us to live like they do and this is a
great thing in Southeast Asia when you
order something we get takeout or you
get anything it comes out of banana leaf
or it's wrapped in a banana leaf and
you're like oh cool and you take the
banana leaf you could just check it you
know obviously you put in a compost bin
but if you don't and it just ends up on
the street it goes away in you know
thirty forty five hundred days so we
need to get to that type of packaging so
guess what there are packages like that
out there that are cost effective from
different materials some of its called
PHA there's other ones out there that
can come from waste product by a waste
to create this whether it's a film a
bottle cap a bottle these different
things that can then be consumer
compostable so literally you can just
drop it in if you litter it it goes away
if you put it in the ocean it goes away
in 45 120 days no nano plastics no micro
plastics just goes away and that is the
holy grail and there are companies that
are doing that today and we're trying to
find them and help them and try to get
people to design with them and that's
what we need to do and in the meantime
we need to stop all this single you
stuff we need to literally ban it
because we are creating a huge mess on
this planet and we just don't realize it
thank you for that description no that's
great go ha yeah I would add one more
thing you can add you can add three if
you'd like so recycling just because
it's recyclable doesn't mean it's
recycled okay so don't trust your
recycling labels if you do recycle you
should still recycle but for the most
part it's probably not going anywhere to
be reused recycled plastics even if they
are recycled are only good for 2 to 3
uses and then they become bad plastics
because they're mechanically recycled
the long chains of plastic become short
chains and they can't make things with
and they become too brittle so literally
you can only recycle them a few times
unlike a
and glass and paper the next thing is is
that people say oh if you don't recycle
you can come post it you maybe you saw
these boxed water thing you know like
boxed water no it's right they say that
you can recycle it you have to go to a
special facility in the middle of
nowhere like it doesn't really get
recycled you hear things about
compostable um things what that means it
has to go into an industrial composting
facility and it needs to get a special
heat treatment and air treatment and all
this stuff to be able to break down that
doesn't work either so we have been
greenwashing recycling compostable all
of these different languages used to say
plastics are green or they're bio-based
wrong wrong wrong the only thing that
really matters now is bio waste based
plastics that are consumer compostable
that's the only thing that we should be
selecting and if we can't select that
pick a different material
do not use plastics okay I know that was
a diatribe it's long-winded but I'm
trying to get that message out to people
that's why I really important that's why
we have long form conversations so so we
can we can unpack some of this stuff so
to speak and you mentioned finding
companies helping companies is is that
done through future shape or is that
done through a different vehicle and for
for people who don't know future shape
could you describe what it is so future
shape future shape is a investment
vehicle from our family to find great
entrepreneurs and companies trying to do
really hard hard developments and create
deep technologies to help fix our planet
fix our society's fix our communities
and get us forward in a green way in
some way green or to enable enable small
and medium business those medium-sized
business owners to then be able to
flourish and get from out from
underneath the system in some way that
they've been subject to for a long time
so we try to find these things and we go
and we
don't call ourselves venture capitalists
we don't call ourselves angels we call
ourselves mentors with money we are
mentors first and we come and we put our
money where our mouth is to help these
entrepreneurs to help these companies to
realize these these goals these dreams
these technologies to help our world and
they take time to build right they take
they take time effort and belief and
what's what's going on so that's what we
do we've invested in over 200 companies
around the world and we and we mentor
them at certain parts of their lifecycle
and and just try to be that team that
can help them with the confidence when
they're down when they're doing the
right thing or help them find whatever
resources they need or help them when
they're trying to learn leadership you
know how to do leadership or find the
right person or do the hiring all those
kinds of real you know things that if
you haven't done them a long time you
know for many years you may not feel
confident about and so you know it's
that nudge to help them maybe we act
like big brother or big sister sometimes
and is is future shape where you're
putting most of your energy these days
or what are you personally spending most
of your energy on so future shape has
been going now for about eight years
maybe ten depending on how you count and
I spent almost all of my time on future
shape and my team you know our team
together we all we all work on these
companies because what we've learned I
learned over the time is we could do one
thing but and start another company but
we take all of the experience the
knowledge the the resources that we can
bring to bear anywhere in the world and
help these other 200 companies to thrive
and really make the change that they
want to make in this world and so we
want to use leverage model so we're
really trying to leverage it and for us
it's incredibly fun and our curiosity is
piqued all the time when they're going
after tough problems and we get to dive
in and be it to be beginners with them
in a way or get to learn from them and
then we get to take our expertise and
then you know combine it with their
expertise and so
it's incredibly rewarding and you know
if people didn't mentor me when I was
growing up and going through that thing
I would never be here today and so at
some point I looked around and go wait a
second I guess that's me now it's time
to you know try to live up to what the
mentors taught me try to live to that
ideal and pass the baton now and and
instill this art this craft with these
other people that we try to help because
it's really important that we try to
pass the stuff down to try to make it
better for other generations it's
important work and you mentioned you
mentioned being beginners and that's
that's something I came up in your TED
talk within the context of Steve and
looking at things with beginners eyes
are there any particular skills that
you're currently focused on personally
or new behaviors either ending or
starting behaviors within the personal
realm or I should say individual
probably better way to put it is there
anything that you're currently working
on well I think you know from a beginner
standpoint in many ways I'm in the
plastics right I'm lil I'm just this I'm
most a little guy calling up researchers
say could you help me I'm trying to get
this well how why does it work this way
you know in reading research papers and
and really going back to school and you
know being an undergrad in a way and
learning hopefully from the best so I
try to put myself in a position where
I'm incredibly curious and I don't I
have skills of analytical skills to
understand maybe what they're doing but
I don't really have the data to really
understand it to that level and so for
me I'm always trying to put myself in a
uncomfortable position
to make big decisions like should we
invest should we do whatever because
that kind of tension makes things I
think really really fun and really
exciting for me I call it brain food so
I try to do that everyday with the
companies and the you know we're doing
we help to invest in impossible foods I
didn't know anything about food science
know anything about that
so go learn about that or we're doing
you know modern meta which is leather
without a cow
right how do you grow skin out without
an organism you know without a you know
a larger organism what does that mean
how whatever so all of these things are
just putting yourself in that point
where you're like I gotta learn this
thing and I gotta be success you know I
got to try to be successful and keep up
with these experts in the field and so
every day is like that so for people who
are listening or watching by any
objective measure I mean certainly
people would consider you successful and
what I like to do in these conversations
and fortunately in your bio it's it's
it's very clear that it wasn't a linear
path from kind of bottom left to top
right I mean you followed a very jagged
path in an in a sense
what do you struggle with what are
things that you struggle with that you
find difficult difficult for me
difficult for me I think is you know
just heavy-duty analytics just anything
that's very analytical I just I got a I
got a feel it I got a I got a see I got
a feel it I can't just sit there and
stare at numbers you know another thing
that's really hard for me is any kind of
long-form writing you know any kind of
just oh no you know that that's really
hard
I'm be a bit I struggle with impatience
you know these things take longer than
you'd like and you know you just you can
see it you can feel it you can grasp it
but you got to go no I can't no no come
on let's just get there and you're like
no okay and you just got to be in the
you know in the passenger seat waiting
for things to happen and so you know I
try to augment obviously the things I
don't like to do with people who like to
do that you know like Mike on our team
is an amazing legal guy and this is what
he loves to do and so I'm like Mike just
go do it like you know that's not my
thing
so we make sure we do that but then when
it comes to the real kind of emotional
stuff of like I want the future to be
here now that I struggle with all the
time like I just don't want to wait why
should we wait especially when we know
now is the time
you know what I mean there was a general
magic it wasn't the time it was way too
early in a list but when you see it when
you cat you and you can see it perfectly
you see the moment it's you're like
let's go we gotta get this done take the
hill come on you know that's that's the
most frustrating thing you know there's
always science fiction and future stuff
but when you see it and you can feel it
you know yes go for it let's get it done
let's let's dig into impatience a bit
because impatience has been I would you
know I would like to think and maybe
this is delusional but one of my
greatest assets and also one of my
greatest handicaps how do you and maybe
this isn't the right question but how do
you think about your impatience or work
on your impatience so that you get the
benefits of feeling a sense of urgency
and pushing when those pushes are
helpful without being just an
insufferable pain in the ass who leaves
scorched earth everywhere because I've
certainly been the latter at points
where people are just cyclized goddammit
to him like [ __ ] doesn't happen that
fast and you're pissing everybody off
how have you thought about finding the
the middle path with that if there is
one I struggle with it every day
you know it's you know there's times
when you're working on things and
working with people when you know you've
been there and it should go faster you
know like you know like okay why aren't
we doing bla faster it's just like get
the stuff out the door it's it's not
like researching and trying to engineer
and find the right correct
you know widget for X Y Z it's really
just the process of getting it done it's
like come on guys you know I understand
you don't want it this is a big risk and
you're tentative about it but we just
got to move on right so you don't want
to have this way to say analysis
paralysis right so you got a bucket it
you got to say okay
this is just their mental state okay we
got a coax them through it and give them
a help them or help myself
to get through that phase and educate
and then we got to get faster then
there's the other phase which is you
know we're just a
process of discovery the process of
getting to insight those kinds of things
and yeah those always take longer and
then there's another one which is out of
control
is you know working with other external
teams that you can't really push all
right and you just have to kind of grin
and bear and you keep reassessing the
partnership and should we be doing with
them and all those things and
communicating them in a very positive
but very direct way like let me tell you
what we're grappling with now it isn't
all rosy and these are the kind of
decisions we have to make because you
are delaying or this is happening where
this is what's happening our business
you know those kinds of things and you
have to be really upfront just like I
was talking about the two managers or
the two people who had to get along and
figure out we got to be upfront and
honest about our partnership and how
it's not working and going what are we
going to do to get over it right and so
I think it's those types of bidding and
then also just taking a step back and
you know I you know you tense up your
your neck like and you just go breathe
make sure I get my yoga done you know
make sure I you know do what have you to
say okay it's just to try to calm down
in certain instances okay so my next
question was going to be related to self
care so the yoga is a perfect segue so
what are some of your self-care
practices whether on a daily or weekly
basis well the diets the first one the
diet is the most important right so
that's that and what is your diet date
well you know it's well vegetarian
without caffeine without alcohol and you
know it's it's an absolute it's the
hardest thing in the world you know it's
is is refined sugars right trying to
just stay off that beast is yeah it's
it's you know I'm I like it too much you
know it just is what it is so you try to
do what you can minimize that as much as
out so that's that eating healthy eating
Whole Foods that kind of stuff then
there's exercise so exercising at least
an hour a day six days maybe seven days
a week right maybe
two hours or three hours are breaking it
up with a hike in this or whatever but
always exercising so whether that's you
know I've always I've been doing yoga I
think 25 years now that was also part of
my reboot yoga for 25 years and it is
I hope the I hope it will be the only
exercise I will be doing when I'm 75 or
older because I think it's the right
balance of mental and strength and and
toning and those kinds of things so yoga
shares a particular type of yoga what
what are the characteristics of your
yoga I'll I'll do it basically I just
have to I have to do something whether
it's hatha Ashtanga Bikram you name it
I'm not gonna be I'm not religious in
that way because I always think there's
more things to learn about and do try
different things alright and and work
with different instructors and that's
tough then there's you know weight
training right weight training and
stretching which I should be doing more
and more stretching you're not doing
enough but weight training for sure I
love to run so you know this is my best
way of exploring a new city is whenever
I go to a city you know for in the fifty
five or six in the morning getting up
putting on the shoes and just running
and just seeing what the city is really
like biking so Road biking for long
distances or even short distances
altitude as well skiing so doing that a
hiking so those kinds of basic sports is
you know what I it's I call it Tony time
I don't have any music with me I won't
have music with me it's almost moving
meditation for me right I it's not just
sitting there but it's moving meditation
so I I think start coming in my brain
and start you know flowing over it and
all of a sudden problems that had gone
unresolved for a days all of a sudden
seem to like because I'm not ruminating
over them anymore just they all of a
sudden the answers come to you which is
great so that's another thing and then
there's sleep
and on the sleep side you know I've I
think you've talked about it as well but
you know I have this device called the
Euler which is I think the next
generation chili pad right oh my god oh
my god oh it is a lifesaver and so now I
swear by it now I buy him as gifts for
friends and have them try mine I'm like
gotta try this but you know you got to
try to get good sleep and and that's
that's also important as as much as
possible I to sort of bookend we're not
we're not totally done yet but to sort
of bookend something you mentioned in
the very beginning alcohol and sleep
I've been astonished looking at heart
rate variability and resting heart rate
and so on which I've tracked with
different devices or a ring and a number
of others to drinks or more and my sleep
is garbage it is such a binary change in
time at what time in the early morning
does it happen to you you know I have
I've looked at this spike there are a
number of different spikes I have to go
back and look at the data I think
they're also making some algorithm
changes with aura specifically and I was
using another a number of sleep devices
concurrently because I wanted to compare
data and try to try to correlate a few
different things so I don't remember the
exact time do you recall when yeah it
was around it well depend on when you
went to sleep and when you had your last
drink but it was always seeming to be
about four to four and a half hours
after that last drink and you went to
sleep when at least for me my heart
would race yep and then you would wake
up and then you and then because you're
you're you know you're just a type-a
personality you start thinking and you
can't go back to sleep and you're
sweating and then you have a horrible
night's sleep and then you know yeah but
that was it for me so you see mentioned
that you you buy the oilers gifts for
friends are there any other devices or
books that you regular that you
regularly gift to other people I
regularly gift the book called in praise
of shadows haha man you're the first
person yes I know this book
okay that's a very very very small book
it's like 80 pages yeah but it is an
insight when you when we talk about
staying beginner and looking at details
and seeing it through other people's
eyes when you read that little book
again you want you don't want these big
tomes you give your friends something
and they're like all it feels like a
obligation but they go oh it's so small
okay I'll read that and they can do it
in an hour and then they go oh so I so
the book is you could explain the book
if you what go for it
well no no no I want to know I mean I
can give some to make some examples from
the book there's one that especially
stuck with me but what why is it's more
interesting to me cuz I get bored
hearing myself talk why do you find this
book interesting I find it absolutely
fascinating because I only grew up so
the book is all about you know Japan
before pre-industrial era and how they
lived at home and how they lived when
Western technology entered the home
afterwards and he was comparing his life
before and after and I I was never able
to do that because I only lived in this
world you know in this post-industrial
world and so he was explaining things
like we had wooden spoons before metal
spoons and the and we had wooden bowls
before we had porcelain bowls and just
the sound of the of the spoon hitting
the bowl when it was wood on wood versus
metal on porcelain and how that would be
grading to your ear and how soothing it
was when it was wood on wood or
artificial light versus natural light
and diffuse light and how your eyes and
how your mental state would be very
different under these two conditions so
it was it was literally comparing this
pre industrial and post-industrial life
through through an incredible writer who
could encapsulate it and you start to go
wait a second I never considered those
details in my life to this level and
you're like that's about staying
beginner right you say yeah oh my god
I've never even thought about that and
this makes me rethink of so many things
that I never thought of and it takes you
to a whole nother world yet the the
he said that that stuck with me most
concretely was the excites to live I
lived in Japan for a year in high school
as an exchange student and lived with
three family so I got to see different
rooms in the house and different styles
of home and there's a there's a short
portion in impress of shadows Bray talks
about how gaudy certain types of you
could consider them sort of Chinese
influenced Japanese say bowls and
furniture are because they're they're
covered in gold plating or painted to
look very bright and gold lacquered
lacquered exactly and what am i one of
my gifts to myself for my after my
finishing my second book which is
definitely not sure it well it is more
of a homework assignment was a lacquered
Japanese saddle actually which which
kind of typifies this and the point in
the book was that it looks gaudy because
things were lacquered in those types of
materials due to dim lighting they were
intended to be looked at in very dim
lighting and as soon as you put
incandescent modern lighting on it looks
terrible and I was like wow I've never
even considered the source and strength
of lighting and then it just totally
changes how you look around at different
objects different historical objects
right it's you kind of take as a given
that the lighting is a constant but of
course it's not a constant in retrospect
exact exactly and and now that we've
gone to LED and Beyond it's you know
it's it's even more so you know that
kind of brilliant stuff so no it's great
I'm glad that you know we share that
love of that book that's so that's
awesome yeah this is the first time this
is first definitely the first time that
this book has ever come up on the on the
podcast how cool I'm really glad you
brought that up
it's a weird little book to I mean it is
it is it is a strange it is a strange
strange book especially for that author
I just wrote all kinds of novels and
everything it was just like a little
weekend project that seemed for him do
you have any other
books that you recommend often or have
reread yourself so yeah there's a I
think I always go back to it because it
makes me think about the ideas in the
book but also it makes me think about my
life which is Thinking Fast and Slow by
Daniel Kahneman and and he and you know
you know Nobel laureate amazing amazing
guy and you know when you read that you
really get to understand how your brain
works and then you also if you can
relate it to yourself and how you make
decisions and other it is about you know
depressing the emotional part of your
body and and about your decision making
but for the more logical rational part
and then I also go well that's good for
some decisions but not all decisions so
you because he who really is advocating
for taking getting rid of one of the
system motional system and I'm like I
like it because the book because I can
really choose which one I want to use
because sometimes there's fact-based
decisions and other times there are
opinion based decisions what's our
emotional based decisions and you have
to really understand which type of
decision you're making for that given
that that given that given point in time
Thinking Fast and Slow I was believe it
or not a subject as an undergrad in some
of Danny Kahneman's experiments you got
paid whatever four dollars an hour to
press spacebar for various experiments
on that thinking fast thinking slow
separation if we look at the emotion
based decisions whether that's what I
don't want to say impulsive but very
quick decisions that are sort of made
with a few million years of evolutionary
input like free pro/con list
well whether to retweet something very
quickly without reading it are there any
examples that come to mind from your
life where you've made very very good
snap decisions where if you had tried to
analyze
that you would have made the wrong
decision yeah yeah well one of the best
decisions I ever made in my life was to
ask my wife to marry me and I didn't
know literally 15 minutes 10 minutes
before I was going to do it that I did
it Wow
I didn't even know I had no I had no
clue it was an amazing week and that was
after 11 weeks of dating and then
literally it was in a span of 15 minutes
from the time I said I'm gonna adore 10
minutes from the time I said I'm gonna
do it till I did it I wasn't prepared I
didn't even know that I didn't wasn't
prepared for her to say no okay what was
a walk walk walk me through this a bit
so go what happened I mean in the sense
that we did it just randomly pop into
your head or was there more to it on
that day
well yeah there was a you know it was
actually a Monday morning of all things
real romantic right no it was so what
had happened was I had some very very
close I have some very very close
friends and they came down they said oh
I met this wonderful woman you know and
and and they were coming in time so gay
I would love to get you guys to meet her
and you know I'd love to just see if we
can all hang out because the worst thing
that ever happens I don't know if you've
had any friends like this is you know
you have a girl or a guy friend or
something and there's a really great
friends of yours and then they meet
somebody and they fall in love and then
all of a sudden you're like and then you
try to meet that person that they love
so much and you're like I just don't
click with them it's like oh I almost
lost a friend oh yeah you know whatever
you know that good it's happened yeah
right it's happened and it's it's
heart-wrenching so you just go okay I
wanted my friends to like cuz I used 11
weeks in and we're having a great time
and I'm like am I in some crazy fog you
know and I was older at the time so I
had a lot of and they saw some of my
other relationships and they you know
they gave me feedback on them so it's
like okay so come on over and so we hung
out the whole weekend together and we
had an amazing time and so that morning
I was driving I was driving them too you
know they said goodbye to
danny's my wife and they said goodbye to
her and then I was gonna drive them to
the airport and all night long it was
pouring rain it was crazy rain and it's
raining all the time till I take him to
the thing and on the and that in the car
sandy and Daniel with my friends they
said oh my god she's amazing Oh God you
guys are so in love it's so amazing you
know the head and shoulders over any any
woman you've ever dated before but a
little lamb like oh my god yeah
and so it's like yeah that's how I feel
and I was in cloud nine and so I drop
them off and then I turn around to come
back because I was gonna pick up my wife
we're gonna go to work or Dena my wife
my girlfriend it's time he's gonna come
in and drive to work together with her
and so I come back and as I'm coming
back the clouds open up a rainbow opens
up and literally this brilliant sky
comes into view and I'm like and I'm
thinking the whole time like well when's
the right time how do you know when do
you know it's the right time that this
is the right person given my you know 15
years of dating history at the time or
whatever I'm like and I'm like it's
never felt like this before no no no you
know and I can work through all the
rational arguments and all that stuff
but you're like at some point you're
like screw that so I'm driving home and
then all of a sudden one of my favorite
songs comes on the radio and I call my
god this is amazing and the rainbow and
everything else and I Drive up and I had
a rosebush in the front of the house and
they're a great roses often but the it
was raining so hard that night I looked
at the rose and I always clipped one and
gave it to her and you know and so I
looked at that and I was like that
survived tonight it was the most
beautiful rose I've ever seen and all
this stuff and he took off the thorns I
clipped and I was gonna just give it to
her
so I walk in the door and I'm like and
she's coming down the stairs with a
basket of laundry literally a backup of
my laundry so like in two weeks and
she's coming over
like what's going up and I was gonna
take her to work she's coming downstairs
and I'm looking at it and I go here's a
rose honey and then I took that you know
and she said oh that's very nice and I
said wait no no give me the basket give
me the rose and I got down on one knee
while she's on the stairs and I said
will you marry me and
like literally like that was I was blind
I just said will you marry right there
and then Wow
that was the Monday morning for the Rose
I had no ring I had nothing
wow that's an incredible story that is
just incredible well that's the that's
the kind of craziness you know that you
know when you know you know yeah and the
same thing happened in different parts
of my life like that like taking the job
at Apple was just like that as well it's
crazy crazy when you know you know
amazing Tony I want to I want to let you
get back to your day but this has been
so fun I really appreciate you taking
the time and I certainly hope it's not
the last time that we get to have a
conversation perhaps we'll meet sometime
in the future
sure anywhere let you know I'm in
different places of the world that will
be sure to stay in contact and no thanks
this has been a lot of fun and we went
to all kinds of interesting questions
that no one ever asked so thank you
oh my pleasure and if people can find
future shape at future shape llc.com is
that the right URL that's correct and
what is your best your best social is on
Twitter is that the best blader people
at tea Fidel happy fa d l fa de l l and
and i'll link to all of that and
everything else do we discussed in the
in the show notes for people so they'll
be able to find you very easily is there
anything that you'd like to say
recommend conclude with suggest any any
parting comments or anything at all
before we wrap up you know I I think the
biggest thing is that we all go through
all of these changes in our lives we go
through failure if you just are open to
learning and you're open to the failure
and pushing hard you know I didn't have
the best start you know I tried really
hard but I didn't have the best start
but it can end up happening if you
really keep pushing whether it's a
failure or a success
keep pushing even beyond success and
keep staying a beginner trying to stay
humble and trying to work with others
because you know that's that's your
superpower at the end of the day yeah
for sure and you know in there in your
TED talk you talked about seeing the
invisible problems instead
just the obvious problems and it strikes
me that you've done that looking out at
the world but also looking inward at
your own subjective experience as in
working with that psychologist to become
more aware of your internal processes
and it's just such an incredible and
inspiring story and I mean for the
purposes of helping people I think it's
so wonderful I'm sure it was difficult
at the time that you had so many
challenges at various points in the road
it's yeah absolutely there was and
there's always challenges and I'm still
learning and I'm still growing and all
those things but you're gonna go through
them too
everyone's got to go through them and
just embrace them and and you know and
just because you see success doesn't
mean they didn't go through them as well
they they most likely did or if they
haven't they will at some point everyone
does oh for sure yeah you should going
keep going
everyone's fighting or has fought
battles that you know nothing about
everybody's got their own stuff thank
you so much Tony
good thanks Jim and have a great day
looking forward to staying in touch
likewise all right my man cheers man
bye bye
you